scott disick and maluma's heated twitter
exchange
all led to this the reality star taking
the singer's lady in his new music video
as my boy the colombian singer dropped a
new song titled sobrio
which translates to sober and its
accompanying music
video which features the keeping up with
the kardashians star
the video kicks off with muluma drowning
his sorrows before he
goes on stage and sees his lady played
by israeli supermodel eden bynes
on a date with scott drama right
well maluma stumbles over to scott's
table sings to them
and messes with scott making himself
look pretty bad
oh and get this sweetie quincy brown and
shanina shake
are also featured in the music video
you're gonna like it you're gonna love
it
at one point maluma takes sweetie's
cigar and smokes it
before heading out to the streets
[Music]
so brio is the first single off maluma's
upcoming
seventh album set to be released later
this year
the singer released his last album
hashtag seven dj
seven days in jamaica in january
of course maluma's new music video comes
after fans noticed a pretty tense back
and forth between the musician and scott
on twitter tuesday
the 38 year old reality star started the
drama by tweeting about the 27 year old
singer quote
wtf with this guy maluma then maluma
retweeted the message and replied quote
what's up with you you want to be me so
bad that you try to take what is mine
and it didn't stop there scott retweeted
maluma's response and added quote
maluma i didn't have to try that hard
get over yourself
you're a joke of course now it all makes
sense
but if there was any doubt the two later
squashed feud rumors when maluma posted
these snaps of the two together on
instagram but this isn't the first time
the two have hung out
back in may scott posted this pic with
his pal writing quote
miss in miami and maluma he slid into
the comments writing
miss you too and now to make the whole
thing even more interesting
maluma was recently romantically linked
to kim kardashian
you know the sister of kourtney
kardashian
scott's ex and the mother of his three
children
yeah but kim put that rumor to rest
during the recent keeping up with the
kardashians reunion special
no i've seen him a few times always in
miami such a nice guy
so nice and while maluma may not be in
love with kim
when et chatted with him back in 2020 he
said he's
all about sharing his love with his fans
through his music
just give love that's that's that's my
position right now in life
right now i feel like i'm a leader i'm a
leader of a new generation
and i have to to them not only reggaeton
only
these dance songs and only uh songs to
go to party on
not it's not only about that also just
sharing love and
ensure we really am